[Music]
i'm just going to say what in sci-fi do
you think of the series that have
actually done really well with designing
ships and things that are
pretty accurate or pretty um
um
that's what i'm looking for
obeys the laws of physics realism bring
out that's a bit of realism to them a
base laws of physics actually if you're
going to build a starship it's what it
would be like um or or could be and what
the series that you just think
no why why do the ships look like that
there's like and i'll throw in the hat
straight away
star trek
there is absolutely no reason why all
the stash the federation starships look
like that
i know they say it's to do with like
warp and stuff but a ball
through warping that's not it doesn't
bother
um so why do all the starships look all
that pretty probably the best
um
that really does work hard to get it
right is the expanse
hands
the uh
when they are when when the script is
written
the
type of of
the
colors of the paper they use
shows the type of gravity that they're
in
you know is it high gravity is it on
earth is it on a station you know it act
or is it weightless i mean they they go
to the po so far
to get it right is they color code the
pages depending on what kind of gravity
the actors are allegedly supposed
uh expose
if you have to create a warp shell let's
just you know sticking with
you know whatever they explain on like
memory alpha or whatever the word we
compete here what not
it seems to be the cells would have to
be
symmetrical
and encompass the entirety of the
spacecraft like the the dish of the
enterprise would be in the middle not in
front
yeah
the warp shell
would also deal with
bits and particles of micrometeoroids or
so whatever in front of the starship
which is also
the deflector dish should be the biggest
thing on it because you're if you're
flying in multiples
logarithms of uh the speed of light then
the potential
energy of an impact is astronomical no
pun intended
yeah well that's why it projects the
there is a lot of power that goes
through the star trek deflector array
and it projects a
b in front of it but yeah i agree with
you normally kevin mckay mccabe also
mentions battlestar galactica
and uh they did a pretty good job of um
you know the the space scenes there's
there's no sound in space you hear the
radio chatter
you know you hear whatever noise you
hear is coming from uh the pilot's point
of view of the horror of the engines or
the apu or st or what or the radios or
whatever adama asked starbuck what do
you hear and she says nothing but the
rain and it's the micrometeoroids
hitting the
canopy one of the few shows i think they
do it quite a lot and there's quite a
few like anime and stuff where i think
they do a really nice job
um but actually the series of firefly
um
i thought they did a really nice job
with one of the um they didn't for the
movie but in the series obviously the
firefly looks the way it does and it's
got streamline it's got engines it's got
slightly some aerodynamics factors to it
but because it comes into atmosphere
but then the um
the
inner core planets have these big
cruisers
but they look like little cities
yeah they were you know had a base and
like towers that look like buildings
almost like skyscrapers like skyscrapers
i think and actually i i really always
thought that is so that is perfect
because
aerodynamics don't matter you can build
a ship to be whatever you just you know
you can slap an engine on the iss and
fly it to the moon if you want to
there's no
um there's no you know there's no
there's no structural reason why it
doesn't have to be anything like a
strong you can make really big ships in
space it doesn't have to be as strong as
what you respect it doesn't have to go
into an atmosphere
well there are structural um
structural uh things you have to taking
into account
uh like the uh
the skyscraper thing the is really bad
design
because the let's uh
so the um here you have the basic ship
and there's all these little skyscrapers
on top yeah well if the thrusters were
on this side right the edge
so all of the skyscrapers would be under
a tremendous force to bend back so you
have a lot of structural
the possibility of structural
failure
along this line here along the edge of
the skyscraper so you have it bending
back until it snaps
so you always want your mass
to be along
your line of thrust the closer it is the
line of thrust the less stress is on the
uh the spaceship
so the whole thing
was quite hard for that to be
an issue in space where there's no
inertia and there's no
oh there's inertia that's i was just
about just about to correct myself not
as much inertia
as thinking obviously when you get into
like pushing you know like 0.7 or or
something of the speed of light then it
matters because you are generating your
own gravity and you you do you just want
space time um but in like
you know slower speeds say getting from
i mean in firefly they don't travel
particularly quickly they go from like
here to mars in days right
you know there's there's quite a long
travel you know they don't have light
speed they don't have
things like that
it's not so much as the speed is the
acceleration
so if you puttering along at
you know i don't know 0.2 gs
you don't get much of a lever arm action
on this skyscraper
but if you're loading up to like five
g's then you get a lot
of bend
so but you if you go to point two g's
you can still get to the speed of light
because you're still accelerating as
long as you're accelerating at slow
speed
long arms like this
matter and
as for the international space station
it is very difficult
to
uh you got to take a lot of care in
getting it up to a higher orbit you know
it always decays down
so you have to really be careful because
every all everything's off the line of
thrust you've got all these solar cells
and other modules going out at 90 degree
angles so you have to be very careful to
nudge it to a higher orbit
but that's because it's relatively and
it's still actually effect by a little
bit of gravity isn't it because that's
why that pulls in i mean the thing the
gateway project they're building just
looks like an iss station and that
they're going to push that over to the
moon and if they ever build it
um
but yeah but i always saw that oh you
don't need to be
pretty
in space that's that was i think what my
point was and the enterprise is pretty i
mean it's a beautiful ship you know but
you don't need to be the spitfire you
don't need to be a spitfire you don't
need to be
an attractive machine
to operate in space unless you're going
to come into the atmosphere and then
you've got a whole other slew of
problems
um
i also like like the star wars designs
they look amazing but are they
practical but they actually do go into
an atmosphere but they've got anti-grav
drives and things so then i suppose it
makes it irrelevant doesn't it
discounting the whole uh issue of
available energy
yeah just kidding who
the x-wing
the x-wing is probably very well
designed because everything's on uh
close to a single line of thrust they've
got the the thrusters on the x-wings and
themselves and so you have
a larger area where the the fuselage can
be in that
pocket that envelope the tie fighters
are kind of decent too because they're
narrow and they're closer to the line of
thrust
there's one
and it's not the millennium falcon it's
where it's got a big long body and it's
got a long arm and then there's like the
cockpit over here
thing wasn't it yeah i want to say
corvette but i know that's wrong babylon
5 the
star
fury google stuff it's been a while
since you watched problem five i always
thought that was a really good design
for like a fighter for space and without
the engines and it could flip and things
and the engines were quite wide quite
far apart so that you know you could
change thrust and you could literally
just i always thought that was as if if
you're gonna have a fighter i'm never
quite sure where the power came from or
where the core was
because it seemed to be that's where the
where the bloke sat and there didn't
seem to be a lot of space for anything
else even though they did mention it a
few times you know like the radiation
leaks and things on fighters and stuff
and i always loved the way it launched
the way it sort of had these little
prongs is good and then just dropped
you know even battle stars
had these long
shooting um
boobs i'm thinking why would you do that
you just have a door and just drop it at
the bottom of the ship surely right um
simplify you know that's what i think
but
i always love that ship
um
hello to walter bishop um he says sorry
just joined
walter we're
we glad to have you
i said in space there's no gravity
there's gravity in space there's gravity
everywhere even though there may be a
gravitational body one billion you know
light years away it still has an effect
on you very very minor there's still
gravity remember gravity is a wave
and so we were talking about creating
your own basically what i was talking
about if you
okay
calm down america
um the america's just gonna don't start
a war just because he's uh just because
he disagreed with you
um
if you travel faster you grab you
generate your own gravity as well just
what we were talking about wasn't it um
calm down i was just thinking spaceships
are designed to look pretty and i would
actually say even a lot of the expanse
ships that they spend a lot of effort to
be expensive they're very very pretty
but i did like how they did like the big
city ship on the actual one right and it
was just a big circle sort of thing and
it was not pretty dark and you know i
think i really like that i think star
trek have always just made ships that
they could turn into models i think star
wars is the same they want to sell a toy
to ask them right um but i always
impressed me that occasionally when you
see tv shows and they go you know what
actually
it doesn't have to look pretty it can be
functional and i always feel like that
so i think that's
i would make a point though actually
about
when they were building the stealth
bomber right they painted it black
yes the air force painted it black and
they said well is is that the best color
because goes well at night actually
black isn't a very good color for an
aircraft really you want to paint it um
like a dark blue or something because
black and and night actually stands out
a little bit it's also not the best
color for the um the heat it doesn't
absorb heat
as well so so ideally you would you'd
paint it like most like a dark gray
but they said well so why did you paint
it black because you wanted the pilots
to feel cool
and it's that's basically the reason
that like a lot of the pilots were a
little bit unsure about this thing and
they wanted to it to look cool
[Music]
you